hey everyone its erik register nurse RN
comm and today we're gonna talk about
angiotensin ii receptor blockers also
called arms and as always after you get
done watching this youtube video you can
access the free quiz that will test you
on this medication so let's get started
as we've been studying these medications
in this pharmacology series we have been
remembering the mnemonic nurse this
helps us remember those important
concepts we need to know for exams so in
again is for name specifically the
family name of the drug because this
really tells us how this medication
works then you for use what's it used to
treat are four responsibilities of the
nurse with our role as four sod effects
and then II for education for the
patient those important teaching points
we need to point out to the patient who
will be taking this medication so first
let's start out talking about the name
we're dealing with angiotensin ii
receptor blockers and these drugs are
also referred to as arms now one thing
to make your job easier is that you want
to remember that these drugs is
specifically the generic name and with
the word certain at the end SAR ta n so
when you're looking at a patient's
medication list you'll be able to
recognize it a lot easier so examples of
arms would be like losartan valsartan
almost Sartain just to name a few
now let's talk about how these ARBs work
and let the name the family name of any
drug you're studying always help you
because it's going to give you clues of
how it works and if you can connect
which system it's manipulating it makes
it so much easier to understand
side-effects and really your
responsibilities as a nurse and what you
teach the patient so we're talking about
angiotensin ii receptor blockers so
that's telling us that this drug is
going to block the receptors that deal
with angiotensin ii so since we're
dealing with angiotensin ii what system
are we're going to be dealing with the
wrath the renin-angiotensin-aldosterone
system and this system deals with
managing our blood pressure especially
when it drops too low so ARBs they
affect the end result of wrath
what's the in result of rass well we
talked about in a review over the RAF
system that its whole goal is to
activate angiotensin 2 to get it on
board so we can have vasoconstriction of
vessels and help increase blood volume
there like the release of aldosterone so
that system increases blood pressure
when we need it to because blood
pressure has dropped so low that the
patient is when it be perfused very well
so they need that system now what an art
is gonna do it's going to block that
from really happening because the blood
pressure needs to be decrease so how
arms work is that they block the
activation of certain receptor sites
that would accept that angiotensin ii
once it's activated by the system and
we're specifically talking about
receptor sites called angiotensin ii
receptor type 1 and these type 1
receptors are found mainly in the
vessels of smooth muscle and the adrenal
glands so if we can block these type
ones from accepting this angiotensin 2
what are we going to do well instead of
vaso constricting we're going to
vasodilate when we vasodilate we
decrease assuming vascular resistance
and decrease the blood pressure well one
thing that angiotensin 2 normally does
is it triggers the release of
aldosterone which is going to cause the
kidneys to conserve sodium and water
that excrete potassium in hopes of
increasing the blood volume so we
increased blood volume we increase blood
pressure well that's not gonna happen if
we block this receptor site because that
receptor site is really what deals with
that so in a sense we're gonna decrease
the blood volume because we're going to
excrete sodium in water and keep some
potassium now let's do a quick review
over wrasse and throw in an angiotensin
ii receptor blocker and see how the
system changes and if you want a more
in-depth look at the RAF's
i have a video where i go over it in
detail but right here i'm just going to
quickly review it so the whole point of
wrasse is to manage ur blood pressure
especially
Everett drops it need sit back up so the
blood pressure drops this will cause the
kidneys to release renin whenever
renan's present in the circulation and
activates a substance in the liver
called angiotensinogen angiotensinogen
is going to turn into angiotensin 1 now
we need angiotensin 1 to get to
angiotensin 2 and in order to do that we
need a special substance called ace ace
stands for angiotensin converting enzyme
and then that turns it into angiotensin
2 so we're there this is the goal of
wrasses the yet angiotensin 2 on board
now we have angiotensin 2 floating in
the system it needs to attach to some
receptor sites so we can get the job
done
you have angiotensin 2 receptors type 1
and you also have angiotensin 2 receptor
type 2 but we're not dealing with these
type 2 so don't even think about those
for ARBs because ARBs work on the
angiotensin ii receptor type one side so
it's what we care about for this lecture
so angiotensin 2 goes and binds with
these receptor sites the type 1 and
whenever that occurs you're going to get
vasoconstriction of the vessels which is
going to increase systemic vascular
resistance and increase blood pressure
and it's also going to trigger the
adrenal cortex to release aldosterone
and when aldosterone is present it's
going to cause the kidneys to keep
sodium and water but will excrete
potassium so will increase blood volume
and remember it's that same concept if
you increase with the water hose you
increase the amount of water that's
going through that water hose and
constrict that hose down that's majorly
going to increase the pressure of the
water coming out of the hose same
concept really applies to the vessels in
our body so that is what it's doing so
now let's throw in an angiotensin ii
receptor blocker what's it going to do
what's it going to effect well we have
these angiotensin ii receptor type ones
hanging out and they're ready to receive
this
Jennsen - but this patient has taken and
our well this connection is not going to
happen this angiotensin ii is not going
to be able to go to these type 1
receptors so we don't have that
occurring we have blocked that so the
result is going to be we get
vasodilation of the vessels whenever
that occurs we're going to decrease -
semuc vascular resistance we're going to
decrease blood pressure it's going to
make it a lot easier for that heart to
pump blood through the body because it's
not hitting that resistance so it's
gonna decrease afterload also you're
gonna get a decrease in preload and
we're going to excrete sodium and water
instead of keeping it but we can keep
some potassium so it has like the
opposite effects so some things you need
to watch out both with ACE inhibitors
and ARBs is that increasing potassium
level so hyperkalemia so we see that
ARBs effect rafts just like ACE
inhibitors but they do in a little bit
different way ACE inhibitors and said of
blocking these receptor sites they
inhibit ACE hence why we call them ACE
inhibitors so they prevent this ace from
converting angiotensin one to
angiotensin 2 now remember whenever we
talked about our ACE inhibitors we
talked about that some patients not all
but some patients can get this
persistent dry cough and they just can't
take the medication so a lot of
physicians will put them on an ARB
instead of an ACE inhibitor now why do
they get a dry persistent cough with ace
inhibitors but not with ARBs well a so
let's talk about that substance ace what
it does is it will inactivate a
substance called Brady Kannan Brady
Conan is like an inflammatory substance
so it activates it by breaking it down
normally so you're breaking down Brady
Khan and you don't have all this Brady
Khan and hanging out causing issues but
if we throw in an ACE inhibitor that
inhibits this ACE you no longer have the
enact
Batian of Brady Kannan with it being
broke down so now you'll have increased
levels of Brady Conant which in some
patients can cause that dry persistent
call so if we switch them to an armed
arms don't inhibit ace so this ace
phenomenon will occur you'll have
angiotensin 1 to angiotensin 2 so we're
not going to be increasing our ad können
levels because ace is going to be able
to activate the Brady können by breaking
it down so that is why a dry persistent
coffee is lot less likely with an ARB
now I'll talk about what ARBs are used
for well we've already established the
fact that args help lower the blood
pressure so people who struggle with
high blood pressure they have
hypertension this medication can be
prescribed along with the patient also
making lifestyle changes because these
blood pressure medicines are not a cure
they help bring the blood pressure down
but the patient needs to if they smoke
to quit smoking exercise diet etc
another thing that ARBs can treat is in
these type 2 diabetic patients who have
diabetic nephropathy and this is a fancy
word of saying they have kidney disease
related to diabetes and how an arm will
work is that it will slow down the
progression of the disease
now ACE inhibitors also do this as well
so keep that in mind they both can help
with diabetic nephropathy in type 2
diabetics and how it does this is that
herbs lower the blood pressure well
patients who have kidney disease they
are able to really filter the protein
like they should so protein will leak
into the urine and the higher the blood
pressure the more protein that's gonna
leak into the urine which can cause even
more problems so if we throw an ARB on
ACE inhibitor it will lower the blood
pressure which will decrease the amount
of protein in the urine which is going
to over time slow down the progression
of this kidney disease another condition
that
cards are used for is heart failure and
remember with heart failure the heart is
so weak that it can't really pump blood
out of it so cardiac output diminishes
and blood can even backflow into the
lungs leading to pulmonary edema and
causing swelling and back flowing and
blood throughout the body
so how an arm can help once you throw
that on board is that remember an arm
vaso dilates so when we vasodilator
CIL's that decreases systemic vascular
resistance and this is really the
resistance that this heart must pumping
it to get blood out of it so if we
decrease the resistance we're going to
make it a lot easier for the heart to
squeeze blood out of it so we're
decreasing the afterload so afterload
again was the male of resistance that
the ventricles must overcome to pop open
those valves so blood can leave it in
addition the way that arms work and how
it manipulates the sodium and the water
with the kidneys is that we can decrease
preload which is the male of blood that
fills in that ventricle at the end of
diastole so if we can decrease preload
afterload make it a lot easier on the
heart to pump in a patient who has heart
failure now let's talk about the
responsibilities of the nurse so we're
giving our patient and ARB and ARBs
lower the blood pressure so a big thing
what we want to do is we want to assess
that blood pressure routinely along with
their pulse and what we're watching out
for is hypotension where that systolic
that top number is getting less than 90
and some patients are going to have a
more increased risk of developing
hypotension especially if they're taking
diuretics along with taking an ARB
because if we're diary seing them where
they're urinating out their extra fluid
volume we can bottom out their blood
volume which can cause even more
hypotension
in addition let's say that they're
started on some new cardiac meds with
their arm you really want to monitor
them closely because we could drop their
blood pressure too low or if the patient
is dehydrated they already have low
fluid volume and how this medication
works remember with the wrasse it
affects how the kidneys deal with sodium
water so you also want to watch out for
this hypotension next you want to
monitor their potassium levels because
remember we are at the end with the
aldosterone what's happening is we're
really reversing how aldosterone works
so the kidneys are going to excrete
sodium and water but it's going to keep
potassium so in some patients they're
batao seen levels can become elevated
and you really want to watch that in
those patients who have the diabetic
nephropathy their kidney function is
already compromised so closely monitor
that potassium level a normal level is 3
point 5 to 5 milli equivalents per liter
another thing to monitor for is renal
failure and you may be thinking okay how
can this cause renal failure since you
talked about in the treatment part what
it's used for it can actually help slow
down the progression of kidney disease
and type 2 diabetics
well renal failure can occur in some
patients here at risk and patients who
are at risk are patients who have severe
heart failure because remember what I
talked about with heart failure their
cardiac output isn't that great so they
really depend on rafts the
renin-angiotensin-aldosterone system to
help them maintain their cardiac output
so they're very dependent on that and if
we go and throw this medication on them
it can lead to renal failure so keep
that in mind and what are some signs and
symptoms that they may be having renal
failure well you want to look at their
kidney function with their bu in and
creatinine it's increasing a normal bu n
is about 5 to 20 a normal creatinine is
0.6 1.2 milligrams per deciliter in
addition you can look at their urinary
output how much have they put out of
urine on your ship if you wanted at
least 30 CC's per hour and are they
retaining fluid where those kidneys
aren't able to excrete the water because
they're failing so look at their daily
weights and just look on their body are
they retaining extra fluid in their
tissues also monitor liver enzymes
especially patients who are at risk with
for liver disease this drug can actually
increase the level so looking at
and lastly I wanted to mention this
angioedema this is very rare to occur in
a patient who is taking an ARB compared
to an ACE inhibitor so it's not likely
to occur in a patient taking are but it
can it has occurred in some patients so
I just wanted you to be aware of it and
this is where you get swelling and those
deep tissues and it can be swelling of
the face the lips the tongue and it can
cause them difficulty breathing so
always look at that with your patient
who is taking this now let's wrap up
this lecture and let's talk about some
side effects and education pieces for
the patient who's taken an art so some
quick side effects would be you want to
tell the patient that they could
experience dizziness because you know
we're altering the blood pressure so
when they change positions or stand up
they need to do this slowly they want to
be on the lookout for hypotension that
blood pressure dropping too low high
potassium level and GI upset now
education pieces which actually tie in
with some of those signs and symptoms we
want to teach the patient to regularly
monitor their blood pressure at home
show them how to do this where they can
buy a device the importance of recording
those numbers and notifying the
physician of anything abnormal what's
abnormal versus normal so educate them
the importance on that also to avoid
salt substitutes with potassium in them
or consuming a diet really rich in
potassium especially if they're taking
diuretics that conserve or spare
potassium like Spyro no act alone and
because this can increase your potassium
levels really high and ARBs already have
that effect where they can increase
potassium so let them know that next who
never abruptly just quit taking the
medication they just don't want to take
it anymore or they have literally just
forgot for a long time to take their
medication because ARBs and aces they
have this thing that they can cause
called
rebound hypertension where the blood
pressure can just get so high and it's
really hard to control I have
this and patients who haven't been
compliant with their medications that it
can occur so tell them about the risk
the best way to prevent it is to never
just abruptly quit taking the medication
also missing a dose so they missed a
dose what are they supposed to do
because they're at risk for this well if
they miss the dose if they remember it
the same day go ahead and take the dose
though they don't remember it to the
next day
don't take that misto so they miss on
the previous day but just take the
scheduled dose for that day and the
importance of lifestyle changes these
hyper anti hypertensive medications do
not cure their hypertension they need to
if they smoke to quit smoking they need
to follow a healthy diet and exercise
which can help with these medications
okay so that wraps up this review /
angiotensin 2 receptor blockers thank
you so much for watching don't forget to
take the free quiz and to subscribe to
our channel for more videos